in the five years since the brexit vote
the uk
left has collapsed and the liberal media
here
wants democrats to pay attention some of
the factors that have doomed labor in
the last elections
such as the rise of the cultural
ultra-leftism could equally affect the
democrats in the united states and lead
to their decline
joining me now nigel farage former uk
brexit party leader
nigel do you see parallels here with
what's happened to the labor party
oh enormous parallels i mean the big
thing that really has driven voters away
from labor
has been just a complete open border
mass numbers of people coming into
britain illegally and
legally and of course the champagne
socialists in london
don't think it matters you know for them
it's just cheaper nannies and cheaper
chauffeurs
but out there in the working class
communities in the old industrial
heartlands they saw
big changes to their lives and that
parallel
you know when you add to that when you
add to that the fact that labor now want
to take the knee
to marxist organizations like black
lives matter
who are happy to see british history
denounced
well these people don't want to vote
labour they came to me in their millions
during brexit they're now voting
conservative they won't go back
and just look at the southern border in
this country
you've got a similar type of crisis here
i'm quite sure
that the aocs of this world don't think
it really matters
but out there in working class
communities in america it does matter
it's a huge opportunity for 2022.
now queen elizabeth uh spoke before
parliament today
and she seems to be tracking our issues
nigel
legislation will be introduced to ensure
the integrity of elections
protect freedom of speech measures will
be brought forward
to establish a fairer immigration system
that strengthens the united kingdom's
borders
and deters criminals who facilitate
dangerous and illegal journeys
nigel are you surprised i'm delighted
i'm just delighted i mean the fact that
you know the the fact that
if anybody gets cancelled from speaking
at a university
they'll be able to get compensation
that's fantastic
and you know to go and vote you should
have to show photo id
we're bringing that in so i don't
understand what the row going on in
georgia
is all about and uh i know the queen
didn't write it herself but i loved it
uh nigel we think about 20 seconds last
summer's riots
that happened in the united states after
floyd we saw a lot of the
unrest in britain as well the attacks on
the churchill statue and so forth
that really cut to the core did it not
yes it did look we know our history is
not perfect but most of us are very
proud of what our little island has done
for much of the world
and when the left want to constantly
attack it uh tear it down
make us feel ashamed of ourselves it
doesn't work
and that's why socialism is dead in
england
hurrah now you have a tour coming up
with freedomworks i understand nigel
it's called the america comeback tour
now they're gonna i love this at
grassroots events meetings across the
country
you spoke in chicago tonight uh what's
next
yeah i'm going on and america's come
back 2021.org
you can look there and see i'm going to
be in phoenix and i'm going to be all
around the midwest this week and going
down to mississippi
speaking to big crowds of grassroots
activists saying
don't get down about the situation we
won
back they tried to deny us brexit we got
it
brexit now has a 70 approval rating and
into the bargain
into the
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else